we've got ebermex candy here as you can
see kendy's renowned scholar and author
who studies anti-racism
and how he says it can improve all of
our lives kendy is now applying that
research which adults have flocked to to
kids with two new books
one is how to raise an anti-racist it's
for parents and there's a picture book
good night racism for kids kendy is the
founding director of the boston
university center for anti-racist
research and a cbs news contributor uh
ibrahim thank you for being here it's a
pleasure to be here uh both books are
really interesting and i think valuable
uh and before you get into how parents
can address racism with a toddler or
even a teenager
talk about why the old way of just
teaching color blindness is insufficient
in your view
i mean that that way assumes that our
kids don't see color
and unfortunately scholars have shown
that by one years old our kids can see
skin color by three years old our kids
are attaching skin color to positive or
negative traits and so if we're just
assuming that our kids aren't doing that
how are we counteracting that you know
because it's dangerous for our kids to
be like i don't want to play with that
that black boy
and and so i want us to counteract that
as parents so the counteracting is the
core of anti-racism
so how do you start teaching uh very
young children how to do that
one of the most beautiful things in the
world is rainbow
and we can teach our children that
there's such thing as a human rainbow
and that there's different sort of
shades on that human rainbow and they
can see their shade
and they can appreciate their shade and
see how it's different than other shades
but they're all the same they're all
part of sort of humanity
my daughter's favorite color right now
is the rainbow and she's like
why wouldn't it be it has all the color
why do i have to choose one right
exactly
i like in your book where you said
racism is a bloodsucker of joy totally
agree with that and you say to do
nothing in a society of justice and
justice is to uphold racism i know
parents say look i don't need my kids to
learn this i just want them to be
children
i want my child to be a child as well
and the unfortunate thing is racism
prevents our children from being
children even you know girls are
adultified particularly black girls but
what's the real issue is that we need to
protect our kids you know from racist
ideas from the idea that dark is ugly or
light you know is beautiful and that
actually prevents them from being you
know children you talk about racially
socializing a child even what do you
mean
well there are all sorts of ways in
which scholars have shown we racially
socialize we've talked about color
blindness there's also
mistrust of a racial group when we say
don't play with those kids and those
kids have to be a particular skin color
that's promoting mistrust for those
particular kids there's also preparation
for racism there's allowing kids to
understand that some people are going to
think you're special because of your
skin color you're special when you're
nice you're special when you're shared
but you're not special because of
yourself
is that how you prepare children for
racism without having a sense of fear
and anxiety because like gail mentioned
there are parents out there that want to
remove themselves from this conversation
completely and then there's parents out
there that just don't know how to do it
how to teach their child to be
anti-racist
it is and you know by the time our kids
become teenagers you have
unfortunately white supremacists are
recruiting white particularly male teens
online that's that produces a lot of
anxiety especially if those white
supremacists are telling those kids the
problem all those other people and
you're sharing with their kid no the
reason for inequities are bad policies
that's what needs to change that's
what's dangerous that's protective so
they don't get attracted to those white
supremacists then they'll look at you
and say you're the racist actually abram
kennedy i was watching someone on tv
you're the one that's a racist who's
who's promoting these ideas teaching
everyone to see race is most of the
opposite exactly well i'm actually
teaching people to see racism
there's a difference like the race is a
mirage
but racism is real and it's you know
who's the most likely to be harmed by
racism are children and you know who
will least likely to engage about it
our children our children that's what's
really prevailing me to do this work
yeah because you said sometimes you're
raising
people can raise racist ideas and not
even know that they're doing it
i think that's very important to make
that a point to me i mean if let's say
you're walking down a you know a street
and you come across a black male and
your child sees that you're scared
you're talking to them
you haven't said anything is it
important for parents to realize that
we are fighting for our kids minds
and their spirits because if we don't
teach them certain things like you said
they will hear and feel and watch and
see things even in the home but
especially when they're outside in
school or even walking around every day
that that is exactly the the point the
unfortunate truth is we live in a
society of all sorts of racial
inequities and disparities all sorts of
ideas
attaching goodness or badness to
particular skin colors we have to be
teaching our children a different way of
thinking a way of being you know in the
world yeah well you know i have a new
grandchild new book in his book club
good night racism i love the last lines
good night hate good night hurt good
night racism good night not a play on
good night moon it's a whole different
thing that you're you're teaching gayle
wants to add and goodbye and yes yeah i
would like to add that and please go to
sleep yeah yeah i had to have a good
night
thank you very much politely spoken like
a father which he is all right how to
raise an anti-racist and goodnight
racism both go on sale tomorrow